يواجه الناس يوميا الكثير من الاغراءات
الاطعمه باشكال مختلفه ولكن كيف يستطيعون
منع انفسهم من الاستسلام وتخريب نظامهم
الغذائي عندما تسعى لانقاص وزنك من المهم
ان تشعر دائما بالشبع حتى تتمكن من درء
الجوع فالشعور بالشبع لمده اطول يساعدك
على انقاص وزنك على المدى الطويل وتقول
خبيره التغذيه ماريسا مور ان هناك مفتاحا
واحدا لتحقيق ذلك وهو
التوازن اذا تبعت نظام غذائي متوازنا فقد
تحصل على جميع العناصر الغذائيه مثل
الكربوهيدرات والالياف وكذلك البروتين
الامر الذي يجعلك تشعر بالارتياح ومن
الممكن ان يساعد ايضا على استهلاك سعرات
حراريه اقل طوال اليوم كما ويوس الخبراء
بضروره وجود البروتين في جميع الوجبات وهو
متوفر في كثير من الاطعمه مثل الاسماك
واللحوم الخليه من الدهون والدجاج
والفاصوليا والمكسرات واللبنه وايضا
الحبوب القمح الكامل هو مجرد خي
وتستطيع كذلك تجربه خبز الجوار والارز
البنيه بدلا من الابيض او حبوب الكينو بدل
الارز وتناول كميه من الخضروات والفواكه
والمياه من شانه ان يقلل ايضا التفكير
بوجبات اخرى طوال
اليوم